okay i guess
let's start um
so yeah so we're we're four speakers so
it's gonna be handheld mic but hopefully
it works um okay so
uh understanding your bank data in 100
ms
this is top sentence is really the main
purpose of this talk we're hiring
across a number of engineering roles so
software devs back-end front-end data ml
uh
please go to jobs at entropy.com
to find out more so and we also have a
booth just outside the door so
we'll be there today and tomorrow
cool so so this is this is a couple of
facts so
every day uh
currently there's there's more than one
billion
electronic transactions happening in the
world and this is growing growing
obviously with uh the proliferation of
internet and you know uh crypto and a
bunch of other factors
um and 45
of these transactions are digital and
this percentage
is also increasing right obviously um
some fraction will always be cash but uh
um
more than half will be digital very very
soon so
and
uh um
your kind of
probably the closest familiarity with
bank transactions is your bank statement
right so when you log on to your bank
online you see something like this so so
previously this was usually sent to you
by a pdf or you know in your post but
effectively a list of your transaction
history right
and uh
you know
up to very recently the only entities
which really had possession of your
history and used it for any any purpose
whatsoever was kind of the large banks
right so these are the largest ones but
also you know just in the us there is
more than 10 000 banks and all over the
world there's more than 30 000 banks so
so this is this is kind of the classic
institutions which took care of your
financial transactions right but just in
the last like five years there's more
and more uh companies which are becoming
increasingly interested in this data
right so so this is just some of them
obviously the largest ones amazon and
airbnb loans google wallet
apple card right facebook libra then dm
then
then um you know maybe something else in
the future
but
a lot of companies are becoming
interested in this data
not only bank but really any tech
company
uh today and in the future so
and so
uh what happens is so so so of course
there is some regulations right on some
standards associated with this data
right so there is some iso standards and
there is some agreements between banks
how this data should look like but the
reality is that
you know um
the world is big and and there's many
banks and there's many different
governing bodies and
there is many thousands of different
standards which are evolving over time
and if you take also into account you
know there's more than like 7 000
languages in the world and bank
transactions are not only in english but
in some cases in in many of these other
languages
and
there's more than 200 million companies
in the world each company obviously has
some association with each transaction
right they there to make money some
companies die some companies
get started every day
and these are some of the numbers i said
right so
200 million companies in the world
25 000 banks 7 000 languages
and just in the us there is 10 000 new
companies getting started every day and
about just as many closing down
so
this data which maybe looks simple and
tabular is actually extremely rich and
more importantly very very unstructured
right
so
again like up until recently you really
needed uh two things right you needed a
lot of common sense and kind of
knowledge of
the real world and also sometimes or
usually some financial knowledge to
really uh decipher this data right uh
obviously you can look at your bank
statement yourself but uh in a
professional setting it does require a
qualified person and it takes around 100
seconds to understand a single
transaction on average right some
transactions are quick but sometimes you
really need to figure to figure it out
and this kind of area was
as you can imagine previously quite
closed off for a machine to understand
because largely of this common sense
factor right
if you know you have some transaction to
walmart how does the computer know what
walmart is right i mean walmart you
might hard code that but what about any
of the other 200 million companies which
just got started yesterday for example
right so
um
but
really in the last couple of years it
has actually become possible to reduce
that figure by about a factor of a
thousand so
and without sacrifice of accuracy or
precision right of using some next
generation ml you can probably imagine
natural language models to do this in
about 100 milliseconds
and
really a thousand times faster
everything right so if it took three
months to get a loan now it takes 20
seconds right if it takes you many years
to build up a credit score now it takes
10 seconds right if you
took you maybe like eight to 12 hours to
fill in your taxes once a year
now it's again a matter of seconds right
and this has really become possible
very very recently
uh
and so
if we take a come back to the backstable
and and kind of take one of the
transactions out there right so these
are some of the key fields of course
there's more but these are the important
ones right so the date the amount uh
debit you know if it's outgoing or
incoming and then some transaction
string which is sometimes easy to
understand sometimes not
and
let's imagine we want a computer to
understand this right so we want to
figure out what's important in there and
then make some conclusions right like
what
what is this spending about where did
this transaction happen who is the
merchant
in this transaction another information
and so
to dive deeper into this we will uh
start with entity recognition and i'll
hand it over to one of our ml engineers
and the head of our entity recognition
platform chatty
thank you ellia
so yeah as
elia stated just right now
there's actually
quite a few models involved in our
pipeline to you know help you understand
and extract some information from our
transactions
so the first uh actually main component
that we have is uh entity recognition
so what is that exactly
basically it's you know you're just
trying to find relevant uh things in
your transaction it could be like
merchants it could be locations uh you
know people
names or persons
uh dates it could be anything basically
it could be you've got a store number or
something and you want to know exactly
which store it was like anything you can
think of and that is relevant
could be an entity basically
so let's uh take the previous example
that
showed earlier
uh so as you can see here
uh you know we
we see am sedan you know looks like some
amazon company us
wa and this kind of stuff like
what are they uh when you look them up
on the internet for example uh you start
to understand that you know this looks
like a transaction by amazon happening
in the us in the state of washington you
know that's the general idea that
you get after looking up some of the
components
um
so how do we achieve this uh on our end
uh like there's a quite a few things
actually to
to do there for having a robust model
because
uh as we said earlier there's so many
different formats and
they're all like you know
more or less understandable
um so
first we're going to talk about like how
exactly we handle the data
that uh
you know we need for this
so first we need to actually uh you know
collect the data so we get like lots of
transactions uh and uh there's so many
of them that we you know a human cannot
just like look at them
um
you know by themselves
so basically we've got uh we've got our
own clustering algorithm basically you
can check out uh our medium article on
our entropy medium on internet we detail
this clustering algorithm a bit more
but basically here i'm going to just
talk about what we do with it
so we cluster
our data and what we're going to do
is
basically
look at all those clusters study them
look at the
how our models basically use them
and see if for example
the current model is stable when it's uh
running inference on them if there's any
issues we also send them to human
labelers that are going to check uh and
we call this actually cluster labeling
because uh the human laborers are not
going to look at individual transactions
they're going to look at
a whole
so that they can get more context
because sometimes transactions even if
there are one entity
they are actually
you know there could be a few several
transactions that are related to one
final
goal let's say you bought something in
10 different uh
you know payments and so on so what
happens here is that after all of this
is labeled there's a review process that
happens using like algorithms that we
have uh to check like uh the batches
quality and also human reviews and it's
a cycle basically until the data is
good enough at least for humans
the thing is that um
like that's not exactly enough because
you know sometimes we've got lots of
data for some patterns sometimes we
don't
so what we do is we also augment this uh
data that
we collect you know just like uh some
some of you know some simple ways to do
it is like introducing like typos or
things like that replacing entities
uh even uh you know using techniques
like mass language modeling uh to remove
words and statistically like replace it
by you know meaningful actually not
entities only but uh
yeah more like parts of sentences
um
and yeah we do this basically
and also like quite a few other things
but
those are like some examples so let's
talk about how we train the our models
so basically
at least for this
specific model it's an attention based
entity recognition model
so this one is uh
particular because it has like
two classification heads because it's
able to understand
uh spans
off uh inside of a transaction and it's
able to then look at those plans and
figure out uh which label it has so for
example if it's a location if it's you
know a person or something like that
and we train it with quite a few data
uh so on some general like an endnote
recognition data uh so that it can
understand like common sense and actual
real-world entities and then we also
train it on a lot of transactional data
you know basically switching domain
by transfer learning
so this model like actually supports
quite a few languages we're
training our models to be multilingual
because
even like for example a similar
transaction in one country
or in even a different uh yeah just a
different continent like can be
like uh very differently uh written or
stated in a bank statement
so you know our model by learning
different languages can share
information between between those
languages
and uh finally we are trying to make our
model like
robust to noise because uh even if we
refine the data that we get before
training it's still noisy like you know
that's it's impossible to get perfect
data
uh we're also trying to make it robust
to shifting distribution because you
know the patterns every time are
changing so
we need to continually
uh have the model learn new patterns and
data and also we're trying to make it
robust to basically word segmentation
which uh sometimes it happens that you
know
the words in the in your transaction are
like
uh
split or they're like uh you know
concatenated and it doesn't really make
sense so you want to be robust to that
uh also
uh so
how do we train it exactly so you all
know the cross entropy loss you know i
mean
you know maybe most of you have already
used it
uh well we don't use that loss um
on our end
uh same uh you all know like the mean
absolute error loss which actually if
you look at it real quick up to a
constant it's actually the same as the
unhinged loss which is a stated below of
it
and we also don't use that so what do we
use and why don't we use those losses
for our training
and what's bad about them if you look at
this diagram here basically it shows uh
here at the
you see the
the gradient of the cross entropy loss
and here you can see the gradient of the
mean absolute error
or the enhanced loss in this case
and what we can see here uh is that
on the cross entropy
loss there is a waiting term meaning
that
samples are weighted differently and
what's the issue with the samples being
weighted differently is that if you've
got outliers or like specifically hard
examples or so on the model is going to
focus on them
and also more importantly
if the data is noisy meaning it's wrong
the model is going to be like okay i'm
not able to learn it so i'm gonna try to
you know the gradients are gonna go
further in this direction which is
actually an effect you don't want
because it could learn wrong data
so that's uh that's one
issue with it and
if we look at
the
uh you know the mean absolute error it
actually does not do that
so
[Music]
the thing is that
cross entropy it's also interesting for
it to
like focus on the hard elements right so
we also want to preserve like some of
this behavior
like both of them have like interesting
sides but they also have bad side so
what do we do
in our case
we use what's called the generalized
cross entropy loss
so basically this loss is a combination
of uh like those two losses
so if like
basically
q is zero then it means that
there is absolutely no noise
so when it tends to zero sorry because
you cannot divide by zero of course uh
and when it tends towards one it
actually tends towards the mean average
i mean absolute error
and um what happens there is that the
loss depending on the amount of noise
that you have in your data set is going
to be able to
uh more um
like to balance a bit more the error
meaning that if you've got lots of noise
in your data set it's going to be
considering all examples more or less
equally meaning that the error will
average
out
and if your data set is less
noisy you know that you can focus on
some of the examples because they are
actually hard and not noisy
so there's uh yeah there's a link to the
paper here when
we
make the slides available
and it's called generalized cross
entropy loss
so we didn't stop here we actually tried
to make it
even better so you know take
let's take the the
like our model like it outputs like this
you know priorities of
its predictions for each entity and it
inputs like the the spans so i just
simplified here the diagram for you to
see
and what we did is basically we made it
smooth so
uh we're actually smoothing the the
spans
and smoothing also on the
entity level so meaning that if the
model
like we don't want the model to be
overconfident when it's doing a
prediction because uh often like it's
just going to be a false positive
and that's not something we want like
it's like
every error matters in in this case
and with this loss basically you're able
to control the slope you see here like
the
the way you're spreading out the
probabilities of the span and
of the entities
and this helps actually uh like uh make
your model less overconfident
uh and it's uh yeah it's uh
an extension to this uh generalized
entrepreneurs
um
yeah
so we're actually doing a lot more
things but you know like this this talk
is not
infinitely long so basically uh quite a
few things that we also work on right
now
to you know make the model like more
stable
and more noise robust
uh and
we're also researching quite a few other
uh
um you know alternatives to to make our
model better like you know multitask
learning which is very interesting if
you want your model to generalize
prompt engineering and and all of
these kind of things
uh so
one of the things i talked about earlier
is multilingual training so i'm not
going to go too much into details
because there's a actually a detailed
article that we wrote on medium about it
uh but yeah our models like basically
need to understand like different
cultures and so on and for that we
developed a method to
train our model which we call like
cycling through languages
uh which basically
you train like it's a very simple method
you train
each of your models with their own hyper
parameters their own epochs and so on
on each of those languages
sequentially and you actually repeat the
process
meaning that you can also change the
hyperparameters between each just each
steps
there's a lot of experiments that we did
here and we even show some extensions to
this method that include for example
adding translation between
languages to do smooth
uh
transitions between them and so on so
i'll let you check out the article on
our
medium blog
so okay i talked about training and so
on but um
of course we need to test our models
like that's uh very important and uh
with so much data you can always like
have lots of horse policies and so on so
what do we do we've got actually quite a
complete testing pipeline
where when our model actually just
finished training as you can see here
we do you know all the classic stuff
like
sorry
like basically just
running lots of metrics you know f1
precision recall per entity
on global entities and so on
just to see where the model is able to
perform well uh or not and just also get
a general like metric on global
performance then also tests of course
for regressions
uh
against like previous models
that we've had in production because of
course we don't want any regression like
otherwise it means that something
happened and we
do not want that
uh so after that we're actually working
currently on a few things like
generating an error report which will
basically
list
all the samples uh per epoch and how
like the model for example generated
labels for them the loss and a few other
metrics and also we we get the nearest
like training uh
samples to those uh
test examples that failed so that we can
check if okay maybe we have a training
cluster that is bad and our test
sample is bad because of our training
and not because of something else
so
that's one of the things we do after
that we are actually working on
explainability right now so
by the way we
will be publishing an article on that on
how to generate explanability graphs
uh for named entity recognition
models
and
yeah after that we have like a
test set that we should never fail
basically get 1.0 f1
if we fail
some of those examples
then it's really bad because there are
very important samples so basically
we're checking for some of
our training symbols to be always
correct
and uh yeah of course like you know the
usual unit tests and staging environment
testing and so on before it goes to
production
so yeah that's basically like a glimpse
of
how we
train this model
now that we've got all those entities
what do we do with them uh
and uh you know what happens next
i will be presented by uh
robin with merchant normalization
yeah thanks cherry
um so now thanks to chaddy and his team
we have um the different entities in
this transaction string uh so yeah now
we want to actually produce the data
that our customers are actually
interested in so they wouldn't be
interested in getting amzn but the
actual website and the merchant name and
some additional information
um yeah so how do we do that
um first of all there can be multiple
organizations found in the string in
this case uh it's twice the same
organization but there can also also be
different ones like a payment processor
for example
um
so right now we're just selecting a
single organization out of all of those
and we're using different heuristics for
those
uh for example that sometimes there are
patterns where um
that's what a beneficiary is
or uh
yeah or if the organization occurs first
in the string it's
usually the more important one so there
are a bunch of different heuristics
um yeah so once we selected one
uh yeah how do you actually get like the
website and all of that stuff
so the naive solution would maybe be to
use a big database with different
companies and their
domains and then
you could do a lookup in that database
but there are some problems with those
with that um
one problem you can already see here so
uh instead of like amazon marketplace
you actually that's actually obfuscated
and you only have
a few of the actual characters
um yeah another problem is that
you can also see here so you don't just
have amazon but you have amazon
marketplace and maybe companies have
like completely different
names sometimes so that's another
difficulty and
another one you can see here but i'll
show an example later is
when you have really companies with very
generic names
um just looking up like finding that
name won't really give you much like in
the example here is napoli pizza you
probably wouldn't
find any company in your big database
that with that name
and finally uh yeah if you have a static
database
you also need to maintain that like elia
said in the introduction there are new
companies
showing up every day and disappearing
every day so that's also a big thing to
maintain
so yeah if all of these problems exist
and the naive solution doesn't work that
well so how do we actually do it
so basically we're making use of search
engines and also
our internal search so first we take the
organization we selected
we generate a query which is right now
relatively simple we just
pass on the organization maybe we add
some more things like the location which
i'll show later
um yeah then we do a search or uh maybe
we already have it in our internal
database
and uh
so once we have the different search
results for that um
we are doing some re-ranking to find
what the best search result is or if
there is a matching result at all
and yeah then finally we have the best
result
so here's in a bit more detail um yeah
so we have these different search
results and the query and uh what we're
doing is we're feeding this to a cross
encoder
if you're not familiar with it it's
basically an nlp model where you give it
both a query and a search result and it
tells you whether the search result is
relevant to the query
so in this example um
the first result from google would be
from forbes but that is actually not the
relevant one
so the second the one with the second
rank the second search result is
actually one we're interested in
and the cross encoder would uh
tell you which one is more interesting
so it outputs a number between zero and
one and yeah one is
a match and zero is no match
so yeah we're doing that on all the
search results and then we're both using
that for finding the best search result
but we're also thresholding this to see
if there's actually no matching result
at all
okay so we have this cross encoder
but uh how do you actually train it
because you need some kind of uh data
for to train it right
um
fortunately it's this is relatively
simple and you don't even need to hand
label anything here
um
if you have a data set with companies
these are there are actually some freely
available ones with millions of
companies
you can
use this and so they have the name of
the company and then some urls so what
you can do is you can take the name and
you can obfuscate it for example remove
all the vowels or truncate it
and then you can do a search on your
search engine that you're interested in
and you'll get a bunch of results and
the nice thing is that from the database
or from the data set you already know
what the correct url is so yeah with
this you can build a data set that looks
like the
two rows there in the bottom where you
have a query a search result and then
just a boolean whether the search result
matches or not
and yeah with that you can train the
cross encoder
so here i have another example where the
name is actually ambiguous worth napoli
pizza so if you just google napoli pizza
you will
find a bunch of results but likely none
of them are actually useful to you
um
so
you can
solve this a bit if you also have um
if your transaction contains a location
then we we find that with nur and then
you can actually add that location to
your search query and then you can
actually find the correct results so in
in this case once you add the location
actually the five top results are all
matches
um yeah
so uh now we have the url how do we
actually get all the other stuff we're
interested in for example the name
the logo and the different tags
um
so for the name what we do right now is
we have the title from the search result
and we can just use a few different
heuristics
uh to find the actual name so then we
can in the beginning we had amzn and now
that we have this title we can actually
get the correct name so yeah this part
is a bit tricky though
then
for the tags so this is just
one example so we have
again amazon.com and then we're
interested in the text for this
one source is from an internal immersion
database where we have a few tags
and then we are also getting it for
example from the snippet you can remove
stop words which is basically the
uninteresting words like on or off here
would probably get removed uh yeah and
that's also another useful source for
text so
that's how we get the tags and the logo
this one is
also fairly simple we just have the url
and then we have both our internal logo
service that has a lot of
different logos stored and we also use
external services to get those logos
and yeah so now that we've done this we
have what we were actually interested in
so we went from the transaction with the
nur
labels we went to the name website logo
and tags
and yeah from here
we i'll
hand it over to johnny who will present
you the label the transaction
categorization
hey guys okay so i promise i'm the last
face up here today so you don't remember
all of us
uh
all right so we have this running trend
the transaction example of amazon like
we talked about before uh so previously
mentioned the two different parts in the
pipeline so the narrow part where we
extract name entities the normalizer
part where we use external resources
search engine to resolve this and the
final part is the understanding part
which is actually understanding
uh at the level of what a human would
get out of a transaction um so there are
a few different things here so i'll just
cause of the chase the
category here is pretty simple it's just
e-commerce
usually we want something more
fine-grained than this this is a pretty
general transaction so we can't get very
far with it
so maybe not the best example here but
i'll show some examples in the future
slides where this can be a bit more
pedantic and much more difficult
so a summary of the data task i mean
this is pi data it's not pi transactions
uh so this is tabular data uh and it's
not just like wrote tabular data so it's
not plug-in pandas and play uh it's
actually a bit more delicate than that
so it's tabular data plus unstructured
components so when you look at a
transaction you see a few different
fields here so there is amazon
marketplace 5942 etc this is
unstructured text and then there's some
more traditional things so there's a
boolean for debit credit which indicates
the flow of money and then there's also
an amount which is 512 which is a float
value
so we're not just doing normal tabular
data but we have to combine it with
these different structures which makes
this a multi a multimodal problem which
has been pretty hot in the machine
learning convenient lately and is a
actual real-world use case for us
so in terms of understanding a
transaction that's even a loaded term
itself there's really kind of four
different things and i put some fun
icons here to make it a little bit less
boring so we kind of want to know who
was involved who were the parties why
did it take place and what was actually
exchanged so i'll dive into these uh
a little bit more in depth so on the
left side we want to know who was
involved in the transaction uh
and particularly who were the parties
involved so we've already covered this
for like the last 30 minutes so i'm not
going to dwell too long on here but the
buzzwords you want to get out of here
are named the recognition and
information retrieval those are the two
things if you're trying to hire a team
to build this which you put down on your
hiring resume
okay so uh the next part is uh the
domain of my stuff uh and this is you
wanna actually understand what happened
so you wanna know what was exchanged
where to or why did it take place and uh
if you're trying to make use of these
transactions for a downstream purpose uh
the actual
inference motive behind it so broadly
speaking there's they're kind of two
different ways this is broken down so
one are lower level categories they are
pretty basic they describe what happened
and if you just walked up somebody on
the street and said yeah i do
transaction categorization this is
probably the very first thing that would
pop in their mind uh and then the second
thing would be a verbal action which is
like yeah isn't that easy and then you
do something like an eye roll or not you
know depending on how nice you are and
then explain the next part uh so the
next part is higher level categories um
and this is understanding like what
happened uh and why so to give you a
quick example of what this could be
let's uh say that you're trying to
understand categorization for a business
and uh the business is very interested
in sales in-person meetings et cetera so
they have a lot of different
expenditures for like steak houses
just the actual what happened is money
was exchanged in turn food was brought
to a table but in reality what was
actually happening is those were
customer acquisition costs they were
trying to build relationships with the
customer which ultimately went down if
they're budgeting for that quarter or
whatever for acquiring new customers so
understanding this uh is more of a human
understanding tasks which puts us into
this uh
regime of
modern machine learning and
understanding things at a more complex
level
okay um
so i had no idea that hugging faces on
before us so the emoji is unrelated so i
apologize if any of you guys are still
in the room um
but uh anyway so tax class creation's
supposed to be easy right i mean just
like talk to her 90 days the call of the
day and then we're done um so great we
can just end the talk there and i'm like
almost over time anyway so it probably
should have but that's not what's going
to happen
uh so there's there's actually more to
this um so we'll dive into some examples
that are a little bit more difficult uh
right here i have a transaction that is
basically the same thing but repeated
four different times and i chose my alma
mater of ucla it's illustrate the point
uh i'm advertising two things entropy
and ucla uh okay so the the transaction
here is just gonna talk about the school
and in general transactions look like
this they have an entity like we can do
all the great things we talked about and
our team has done a really outstanding
job building earlier so we can identify
like ucla is right here we can identify
id numbers we can say look it was an
external transfer we could even find the
date so we can do all of the fun entity
recognition but the problem is is that
we really don't know what this was for
and the the different parts of tabular
learning now start to play a really
critical role it's not just an nlp
problem so if you look here the things
that are shifting are amount and entry
type mostly and the text actually
doesn't really matter
so in in the very first example you have
an incoming payment for roughly sixteen
thousand dollars uh
and anybody that uh has gone through a
schooling system knows this is probably
some kind of disbursement so maybe the
recipient like won a grant or an award
or has some kind of loan uh if the
amount is a little bit lower like say in
like the 2000 to 3000 range um
i'm not going to say what my student uh
my seller was a graduate student but it
can be in this range and
it's a totally different interpretation
if it goes even lower then all of a
sudden you have a very different picture
of what happened so often times if you
purchase something at a large place like
university uh it doesn't matter what
you're purchasing so if you go to a
campus bookstore you go to a campus
coffee store or whatever it all gets
billed in the transaction statement as
following from the university itself so
in this case here 699 is actually most
likely to be something like coffee and
then finally we'll do one more example
which is very similar like i just said
if you raise that amount a little bit
higher to 160 and make it outgoing it's
very likely it becomes a textbook
so what has now become a simple problem
is actually quite difficult because the
reality is is that
when we do transaction categorization we
are bringing in a ton of external common
sense knowledge and this is exactly what
iliad brought up before which is we need
to teach our models to have a basic
understanding kind of like of how human
society interacts like how economies
work how much goods and services cost
what their value is when there isn't
like insane inflation um which i guess
is a
you know changing distribution thing
that we have to deal with as well uh in
all this
anyway so um i guess what makes us hard
is that we also get a lot of this is
incomplete data so we we can't even
definitively have transactions that are
as clean as the example i gave you
before
uh so in order to to solve this problem
we do a few things so we build natural
language models that are capable of
these complex higher level
inferences and then we also add in
additional queries so we use
attention-based models that
have the structure to attend on
and be able to bring in the arbitrary
complexity that we need
we also
put in multimodalities as we talked
about earlier and that's easily put
together with nlp uh
i'm almost there so we also do multitask
learning um and this has been kind of
the emergent trend in the last couple
years with machine learning is that you
can solve very difficult tasks by
creating many different tasks each of
varying level of complexity and it turns
out that transactions actually have
multiple different views associated with
them
based on who the account holder is and
this is a very rich thing and then
finally here's a plug for this thing
called custom models so some graphs here
uh basically you can tune things
yourself it's really fun i made them
here's some fun tsne and uh
this is more about our culture and
we're hiring because remember that's the
point of this talk
[Applause]